à première vue les danseuses du crazy
horse se ressemblent toutes
même uniforme même physique derrière les
habits de lumière se cache use ou les là
et tina des jeunes femmes originaires du
japon du liban et de guadeloupe
leur recrutement illustre la volonté du
cabaret de coller à une société où la
diversité est une réalité la diversité
dans la sélection n'était pas là
aujourd'hui
à travers différentes je pense déjà de
colo barras collaboration noémie lenoir
qui est des guest stars des gens comme
swizz beats qui sont venus les jeunes
danseuses se reconnaissent ses dix
balles ya une place pour moi aussi la
fais attention daniela alias skin à
tobago a poussé la porte du crazy en
elle n'a pas de formation de danseuse
mais sa pratique de la gymnastique
rythmique l'à beaucoup aidé la jolie
guadeloupéen infirmière de formation a
longtemps hésité avant de tenter les
castings du crazy pour moi je n'ai
jamais être prises j'avais connu une
seule noire au crazy depuis que je
regardais toutes ces vidéos sur tous les
réseaux depuis j'étais petit c'était
miss talent ou là justement que j'avais
découvert que je trouve est sublime mais
j'en avais vu qu'une je n'ai vu qu'une
seule je savais qu'elle était plus au
crazy à l'époque où moi je voulais je
pouvais en tout cas pouvoir prétendre
être sur cette scène et
c'était juste un rêve c'est un rêve qui
se réalise juste d'avoir un si tu
l'avais vu avant
mais je suis surprise par le nombre de
candidates qui et qui postule maintenant
qui tentent et qui sont des fois même
pas les danseuses mais qui réalise qu on
ne réalise au plaisir il ya beaucoup
d'effets de couleur on a entendu que
vous cherchez plus de diversité et voilà
il prend du courage et postule avait 12
ans la première fois qu'elle a vu le
crazy horse à la télévision elle était
loin d'imaginer pouvoir intégrer la
troupe
quelques années plus tard tous les soirs
elle se prépare à monter sur scène elle
se souvient encore du jour où la
responsable du casting lui a annoncé
qu'elle était prise actuellement je
continue mon métier mais en tant
qu'intérimaire aux vacataires
mais j'avais j'étais plus du tout en
poste donc en fait j'étais libre comme
l'air et je leur ai fait comprendre tout
de suite que si c'était demain la
première répète j'étais là donc c'était
juste jean déploie
au crazy horse qui n'a rejoint une autre
antillaise venus océane originaire de
martinique
grâce à elle d'autres jeunes femmes
auront sûrement le courage de tenter
leur chance aux six auditions organisées
chaque année
[Applaudissements]